[Music]
in mosquito birth-control news a what of
course that makes me not want to have
sex s-sure yeah submitted by [ __ ] yeah
yeah exclamation point included never
good that's what I was going yeah one of
the best movies researchers have
discovered a potential birth control for
mosquitoes oh thank you the man for
mosquitoes [ __ ] yeah that's awesome
what do you hate them from everything
what is the point what is the point
though because we kill hundreds of
thousands of dead people and people why
do we need what they're here to kill we
need them because they're part of the
ecosystem like bats eat mosquitoes so we
can't completely get rid of well why do
we need bats why can't we just get rid
of malaria well there are there are
areas that mosquitoes never really
existed but then they [ __ ] rampage
like Hawaii reading this article on like
damn mosquitoes are [ __ ] crazy
so they adapt to whatever we do as
humans they like good real if I can
learn how to do cell phones so what they
do it like those three handfuls nets
like the bed net yeah so people would
sleep in them obviously and they're like
it will trap the mosquitoes from biting
them in the night which used to be their
prime time when they would bite you but
then they adapted to that to start
biting people during the day cuz they're
like they're out of their neck they know
me so they used to do while we were
sleeping
Wow then we've developed all these
insects insecticides and a lot of these
mosquitoes have become resistant to most
of these insects it seems that way
doesn't use it and then like the [ __ ]
miss cuter repellent and I still get bit
I'm like oh dude I say we give the
planet to them and we go to space if
they can get to [ __ ] space they
deserve to buy this watch one [ __ ]
comes on board and finds a way to do oh
my god yeah
it just takes one no one what they're so
they're so resourceful that they find
out how to duplicate like so oh that's
like the feei they just like become with
one with the human yeah that was so
creepy
yeah so researchers at the University of
Arizona say that they have discovered a
potential protein that exists only in
female mosquitoes and so what they do is
they block that protein and then when
the female lays eggs it's laid with
defective shells causing the embryos
inside to die so this is like a birth
control method so they can't be they're
not killing the mosquitoes they're just
not allowing them to create more that's
my question is what would PETA say sure
Peter he would say that they should live
in houses next to us
the only kind of Peter I like is the one
that's like a bread you know they kill
um mosquito-borne diseases kill about
2.5 million people worldwide a year and
cost 3.5 billion dollars worldwide for
treatments how do we do this in resort
towns so that I can go to the beach and
I have to wear a ski does I know alright
so they're trying to do it right now the
type of way to mass produce a solution
for the world to like really just bring
down the mosquito population but how do
they do it without absolutely
eradicating mosquitoes because we can't
eradicate that if we do it we I think
that'll be we do I would say like
eradicate them in areas that they were
they weren't naturally there so I would
say eradicate them in areas that they
were invasive species that like so for
example Hawaii or I don't know do they
come from Southeast Asia I don't know
you know so find all the areas that
didn't traditionally have mosquitoes and
take them all out because you're just
balancing back the ecosystem what if
there was always ski toast or what if it
was always what if they were part of
Pangaea what if they're part of Pangaea
and then they're gonna be on there
Pangea they were this big
you know yeah they're a different kind
probably like what if the mosquitos that
are in like developing countries are
native though to that they leave them
there but it's evolved a country that's
like people are suffering that's the
question - yeah I'll have and did you
know that I think it was sickle cell or
the recessive gene of sickle cell is the
natural human protection against
mosquitoes so it's pretty much like one
negative aspect of our genome is
actually has a positive thinness to be a
mosquito repellent yeah so mosquitoes
don't want to bite you because you have
less blood flow or some sure no it's
more like your blood kills them or
something like yeah it's kind of I don't
know what the details were but it was
something to do with mosquitoes and it's
like a natural repellent against them
but when there's two people with that
gene then then it's like more of a
chance that their kid will have sickle
cell you know like um what is it how
consultor kills birds or some [ __ ] yeah
makes it blow up I wish if I took blow
up that's what the urban legend on the
playground was like if you give it to
Siegel use him blow up on foot I heard
that too and I pictured the Shrek scene
from when she was singing how do I eat
something that makes mosquitoes blow up
that's what I was wanting to know you
know poet he says he'll see if he sees
one land on his arm or whatever he
started flexing really hard in hopes
that it like blows up but it does it
does it he was one of the shot it
doesn't know I try to like I'm like I'm
squeezed [ __ ] blood into you but then
it's one when it doesn't work then I
grab them then when I already have them
in my hand i smears [ __ ] your life into
my fingerprints you need to write a
letter to the scientific community and
let them know that you tried flexing and
it didn't work just so that they know
don't spend any more money or research
you'd be published on public it just so
you guys don't waste time in this field
I tried it you know does not work in
here my reflux in they don't work I'm
sure they didn't try that I know and
they're 10 years of research that's
exactly on the top of my letter I start
with hey bro I bet you didn't know yeah
hey Brooke dear bros and dear brothers
and then in parentheses and your and
chicks in the scientific community at
the bear head by the way these are my
stats i squad this much I just let you
know I do think somebody out there is
doing that
I know keeping them all informed you
know we're in a tulum so when you're on
the beach I think the wind is strong
strong enough where I didn't get bit
once who was born the mosquitoes and
things so I don't think you try to come
down and then uh but when we were having
dinner every night I would put on
mosquito repellent and then I didn't get
bit one time and then as where you eat
outdoors and then the one time where I
was like I think I'm good and I didn't
put it on I got lit up like 20 times in
like five minutes
yeah and Jill I was like all fine she
thought bathroom wishes she ran back to
her room to grab this brief or you know
what I thought mosquitoes didn't like
the cold and you know how it's been
raining recently they're still around
yes dude I got bit up like a
[ __ ]
granted rain oh you need water oh my god
cuz I was in my backyard [ __ ] doing
karate like a [ __ ]
and I was like it's sprinkling dirty
shirtless karate like a [ __ ]
like it was it was yeah it was
sprinkling but I had to get my sweat on
you know yeah and I was bit the [ __ ] up
and I was like what the [ __ ] is
happening they mate in water do they do
they give birth in water in water I just
read in this article from reading all
about mosquitos that they did during the
ring yeah I mean yeah but I thought it
was like hot tropical rain okay right I
thought mosquitos traveled like birds
and went to the hot zone and came back
yeah
they chill here in the winter it's been
cold as [ __ ] I didn't think mosquitoes
like the cold
I thought wrong karate man I try to [ __ ]
it does Mohammed's have mosquitoes
yeah we're did this know where its nose
would that have I feel like every
tropical place has it I think they do I
think they do but they travel during the
snow or they [ __ ] incubate somewhere
or some [ __ ] dude even Bali it's like
dude just it's like this island in the
middle of the [ __ ] ocean has
mosquitoes I'm like damn how did they
get here dude
I know it's just moist so where did they
come out of like what did look at
there's probably some moist puddle
somewhere and they just lay all there
for sure though it doesn't take much
water for them to like turn weird the
first one come from
I saw them form in my backyard before no
no this is sailors like you know like
when people would travel and then they
would the fleas and [ __ ] yeah because
they would you know they might have a
water puddle and a pirate
yeah like on the boat or whatever so do
you answer a question yes they're in the
Bahamas damn they're everywhere
I feel like they met might have came
from Africa and indeed went on on the
ships or something okay let me google
this cuz I wanna go to Bahamas next I'm
like oh man is there no mosquitoes well
the thing is the tropical area is South
Africa right okay that's where they came
from
yep because Cape Town was a big trading
port believed that mosquitoes originated
in South Africa Wow mosquitoes in Elon
Musk that's what caused a trade like
they made sure these are all yeah
because if you think about the boats if
they if they get on the boats law
there's humans and there's water and in
big they stay on the boats and then if
they land in like Asia or the Americas
or whatever then it's like they fly off
the boats I hate them I hate them too
because that's what I heard like and why
the they were saying like cuz I was like
I wonder what the natives were doing
when there were so many mosquitos like
what was their repelling like nothing
they weren't living life having ever
that's when I started researching
mosquitos because they're like they
didn't have mosquitos before what do you
call it like like colonialism or
whatever that's when that's when they
got on the ships and then they came up
and am I
so you're telling me that they didn't
have to [ __ ] do this [ __ ] damn post
type and they didn't have off either
what's that uh what's that herb this
citronella yes shinola
yeah they had that you're saying that
the that they have fossil evidence from
a mosquito from 46 million years ago
oh yeah that's one that Michael Crichton
based er super calm yeah they suck the
blood out of that [ __ ] mosquito
trapped in amber or some [ __ ]
[Music]